En julio de 1969,
tres estadounidenses volaron al espacio.
Viajaron a la superficie de la luna,
dieron el famoso gran salto para la humanidad.
Buzz Aldrin y Neil Armstrong caminaron sobre la superficie,
plantaron esta bandera.
Se celebra, con razón, como momento triunfante en EE.UU.
Pensamos que fue un logro maravilloso.
Sin embargo, no solo dejaron esta bandera,
también dejaron una placa.
Esta placa es un hermoso objeto,
del cual me gustaría hablarles un poco.
Primero, podrían notar que hay dos globos,
que representan toda la Tierra.
También está esta hermosa declaración:
"Vinimos en son de paz en nombre de toda la humanidad".
A primera vista, parece un bello lenguaje poético,
pero está escrito con un tipo de letra perfecto para este momento.
Parece industrial, parece diseñado.
Tiene el nombre más adecuado
que se le podría ocurrir para un objeto en la luna: Futura.
Deseo hablarles de tipos de letra,
y por qué es perfecta para este momento.
pero en realidad es más que algo ceremonial.
Cuando todos Uds. llegaron aquí hoy,
tuvieron que pensar en tipos de letra.
Puede que no lo sepan,
pero todos Uds. son expertos inconscientes en la tipografía.
La tipografía es el estudio de cómo los tipos de letra llenan nuestro mundo,
son el lenguaje visual de las palabras que usamos.
Sin embargo, hay algo gracioso en esto.
Probablemente no sean como yo, nerd de la tipografía,
tal vez algunos lo son, pero no importa si no lo son,
porque yo podría pasar horas cada día
escogiendo la tipografía perfecta para el proyecto perfecto,
o gastar miles de dólares cada año
buscando unas con las características adecuadas.
Pero Uds. pasan horas cada día analizando tipos de letra.
Si no me creen, piensen en cómo llegaron aquí.
Cada uno juzgó por las señales,
y quizás utilizando su móvil,
qué señales seguir y cuáles ignorar.
Analizaban tipos de letra.
Quizás al comprar un nuevo producto,
reflexionan sobre si es costoso,
barato, difícil de conseguir, o fácil de encontrar.
Lo curioso es que,
si bien podría parecerles ordinario,
pero en en el momento que ven algo fuera de lugar
lo reconocen de inmediato.
(Risas)
Lo que amo de la tipografía
y lo que amo de los tipos de letra y de Futura
es que, para mí, lo que estudio se encuentra en todas partes.
Cada calle que recorro, cada libro que tomo,
cada cosa que leo está llena con lo que amo.
Una vez entendida la historia de lo que pasa con la tipografía,
se tiene una historia de todo lo que tienen delante de Uds.
Aquí tienen la tipografía Futura.
Como ya les he dicho, este es el modernismo en miniatura.
Esta es la manera en que el modernismo impregnó este país
y se convirtió en la tipografía más popular y más omnipresente
del siglo XX.
"Menos es más", ¿no? Estos son los aforismos del modernismo.
El mismo fenómeno ocurrió en las artes visuales.
Concetrémosnos en lo esencial, en las formas básicas,
en la geometría.
Esto forma parte intrínseca de Futura.
Podrían notar que las formas inherentes a Futura
son círculos, cuadros y triángulos.
Algunas formas se basan en un círculo,
como el O, el D y el C,
y otras tienen el vértice puntiagudo de un triángulo.
Otras parecen haber sido diseñadas con una regla o un compás.
Parecen geométricas, matemáticas y precisas.
De hecho, este sistema es significativo en el diseño de la tipografía,
para no parecerse a otras tipografías y para ser nueva.
Aquí la tienen en tamaño normal, en tamaño mediano y en letra negrita.
La familia de tipografía se compone de diferentes elementos.
Fue una ruptura consciente con el pasado
algo que parece hecho por una máquina, no a mano.
Cuando digo no hecha a mano, esto es a lo que me refiero.
Esto es en lo que quizás piensan cuando
se escribe una letra con un pincel o un lápiz caligráficos.
Varía el grosor de las líneas.
Incluso las tipografías más tradicionales, como Garamond,
conservan los vestigios del pasado,
donde lo alto del A es bastante fino
y más gruesa abajo,
para dar la impresión de que había sido escrito a mano.
Futura, por el contrario,
está diseñada para parecer algo que no se ha tocado,
como algo creado por máquinas,
para una era de máquinas, industrial.
Pero hay un truco visual aquí
que Paul Renner, el diseñador que que creó Futura en 1927, utilizó.
Si observan cómo
la forma circular se une con el eje vertical,
notarán que se estrecha un poquito.
Esto es una de los cientos de maneras
en que se diseñó para verse geométricamente perfecta
incluso si no lo es matemáticamente.
Es lo que los diseñadores tipográficos hacen
para hacer que sus tipografías funcionen cada día
Otros diseñadores hacían esto a la vez en Europa y en EE. UU.
Estos son excelentes ejemplos de Europa
que intentan crear algo nuevo para una nueva era.
Hay otras en Alemania que,
en cierto modo, se parecen a la de Futura,
quizá con distintas circunferencias y proporciones.
Pero ¿por qué Futura dominó el mundo?
En este caso, si leen estos títulos,
sus nombres no son fáciles de pronunciar:
Erbar, Kabel Light, Berthold-Grotesk, Elegant-Grotesk.
Estos no son nombres corrientes.
Comparándolos con Futura,
queda claro que el equipo de marketing tomó una buena decisión.
Lo increíble de este nombre,
lo que contiene este nombre,
es la evocación de la esperanza y de una idea de cómo será el futuro.
Esto ni siquiera es la palabra alemana para 'futuro',
no es una palabra alemana.
Escogieron un término
que resonaría en un público más grande y universal.
Cuando se le compara con lo que se hacía en EE. UU.
estas son las tipografías de la misma época
de los EE. UU. en los años 20,
bold, brash, braggadocios.
Casi evocan las fluctuaciones erráticas del mercado bursátil
en los años 20.
Resulta evidente la cualidad revolucionaria de Futura.
Me gustaría tomar distancia y hablar de un ejemplo de esta tipografía.
Esta es una revista que conocemos, "Vanity Fair".
Esto es lo que parecía en el verano de 1929.
De muchas maneras, no hay nada inusual en el diseño.
Este es muy típico de los años 20.
Hay una foto de un hombre importante,
Franklin Roosevelt, el entonces gobernador de Nueva York.
Todo parece centrado, todo parece simétrico.
Todavía hay un poquito de decoración,
quizá preservando vestigios de una época más romántica
y no tan modernista.
Pero todo parece robusto.
Incluso hay capitulares para orientar al lector.
Todo cambió muy rápidamente y en octubre de 1929,
un diseñador de Berlín rediseñó el "Vanity Fair".
Esto es cómo se ve con Futura.
En reemplazo del gobernador,
se presenta una foto de un entorno abstracto y maravilloso,
en este caso, el océano.
Los capitulares han desaparecido por completo.
El diseño de página pasó de ser centrado a ser asimétrico.
Cuanto más se lee la revista, más se vuelve radical,
en este caso con la asimetría.
Se ven ilustraciones de Pablo Picasso que se mueven por la página,
ignorando la división entre las dos páginas.
Hay algo más radical aún.
Si observan a Futura de cerca, puede que noten algo.
Es posible que no lo detecten,
pero no hay ninguna mayúscula en el título ni en las leyendas.
Eso les podría parecer poco radical,
pero sea cual sea la revista, el libro o el sitio web,
es difícil encontrar material que no contenga mayúsculas.
Sigue siendo una idea radical.
¿Por qué es tan radical?
Cuando se piensa en lo que las mayúsculas indican,
resulta que señalan algo importante,
ya sea nuestros nombres o nuestros títulos.
O tal vez el nombre de nuestras empresas,
o incluso nuestras marcas.
En cierto modo, EE. UU. es la patria del uso de las mayúsculas.
Amamos escribir todo en mayúsculas.
(Risas)
Pero piensen en lo radical que sería
publicar una revista que sacara todas las letras mayúsculas.
Esto pudo haber tenido el mismo impacto político
que concedemos a asuntos como los pronombres hoy en día.
Los años 20,
estos son los años que siguen la revolución comunista en Rusia.
Para ellos, este diseño representaba la infiltración de socialismo en EE.UU.
Todas las minúsculas eran una señal de igualitarismo,
para simbolizar que todos estaban en igualdad de condiciones.
Esto sigue siendo una idea radical.
Piensen en cómo Uds. usan las letras mayúsculas
para conceder más poder a una palabra.
Ellos utilizaron Futura para transmitir este concepto.
Otros diseñadores utilizaron Futura de manera diferente,
aportando distintas ideas de modernismo,
ya sea nuevos estilos de ilustración,
o ilustraciones interesantes en forma de collage.
O nuevas cubiertas de libro procedentes de Europa.
Esto es lo curioso.
En los años 20, no era posible descargar una tipografía en la computadora.
Se necesitaban piezas de plomo.
Los estadounidenses que querían adoptarla,
e integrarla en su propio sistema,
como elemento tipográfico ordinario,
en comerciales u otros soportes,
tenían que poseer tipos metálicos.
Entonces, como capitalistas perfectos, ¿qué hicimos?
Hicimos toda clase de copias.
Copias sin ninguna relación con el nombre Futura,
pero que eran idénticas a ello,
ya sea Spartan o Tempo.
Cuando estalló la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
las empresas estadounidenses intentaron boicotear productos nazis.
Pero dijeron, "Sírvanse de nuestras copias.
Utilicen 20th Century, Spartan, Vogue y Tempo.
Son idénticas a Futura".
Mucha gente ni siquiera se molestó en aprender los nuevos nombres
y acabó llamándolo todo 'Futura'.
Los estadounidenses adoptaron esta tipografía,
la conquistaron y se apropiaron de ella.
Al final de la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
se utilizaba en todas partes en EE. UU.,
ya sea en catálogos, atlas,
enciclopedias, gráficos, tablas,
calendarios, material político,
o incluso para el logotipo de un nuevo equipo de fútbol.
De hecho, se utilizó para algunos de los comerciales más importantes
del siglo XX.
Es en este contexto, cuando el gobierno estadounidense de posguerra
eligió una tipografía para nuevos mapas y proyectos,
eligieron Futura.
Fue una elección poco sorprendente y poco radical,
no tuvo nada que ver con el comunismo.
Se utilizó en algunos de los mapas más importantes,
como este mapa de la fuerza aérea en 1962,
o estos mapas utilizados en Vietnam en 1966.
No fue sorprendente
que cuando los astronautas iniciaron el programa Mercury,
y John Glenn orbitó la Tierra,
los mapas y gráficas utilizados fueran en letra Futura.
De hecho, cuando Mercury se convirtió en Apolo,
Futura se empezó a utilizar con cada vez más frecuencia.
Aquí como plan de seguridad,
apareció también en los paneles de instrumentos
y en dispositivos de navegación.
Hasta en diagramas representando el funcionamiento del sistema.
Lo increíble es que
no solo se utilizaba en documentos distribuidos a la gente.
Se empezó a utilizar como interfaz
para un sistema que ayudaba a que los astronautas
manejasen la máquina.
La NASA no era una gran empresa que produjera todo.
Había cientos de contratistas,
Boeing, IBM, McDonnell Douglas,
que fabricaban otras máquinas.
Imagínense si los astronautas hubieran usado distintas tipografías y sistemas
para cada componente de sus transbordadores espaciales.
Esto habría sido imposible de dirigir
y habría sido una sobrecarga cognitiva
cada vez que utilizaban un nuevo sistema.
En este caso, Futura se utilizó en la interfaz
para ayudarles a gestionar complejidades y facilitar su funcionamiento.
No solo estaba presente en botones, sino también en etiquetas,
raciones de alimentos,
y en juegos de herramientas.
Se utilizó en botones y palancas en forma de instrucciones.
De hecho, en algunos lugares
donde las cosas complejas tenían que aparecer más sencillas,
se imprimieron instrucciones completamente en Futura
a fin de permitirles saber qué hacer en ese momento.
No tenían que recordar todo de memoria,
todo era visible y legible para todos.
Futura ayudó a hacer ese sistema,
que ya era un sistema complejo y muy difícil de manejar,
un poquito menos complejo.
Es más, la primera y última cosa que veía un astronauta
al entrar o salir de la nave espacial
era, sin duda, Futura.
Uno de mis ejemplos preferidos del impacto de Futura
es esta cámara fotográfica.
Esta es una Hasselblad hecha por una empresa sueca.
Es una muy buena cámara, podrían haberla usado antes.
Es altamente apreciada por los fotógrafos.
Es una buena cámara
Si saben algo de cámaras
notarán que hay algunas modificaciones.
Se han puesto etiquetas sobre los carretes
y sobre otras partes de la cámara aquí.
Esto permitió que la NASA
sacara lo mejor de sus astronatuas.
No son fotógrafos, tampoco son expertos en el arte.
Sin embargo, las etiquetas con letra Futura
permitieron que supieran usar esta cámara.
En este caso,
Futura les concedió legitimidad en cuanto a los objetos que manejaban.
Por ejemplo, no sacar el rollo fotográfico antes de que se exponga.
Sin esto, nunca habríamos obtenido
algunas de sus maravillosas fotos sin esta etiqueta.
Al ver algo tan decorativo como este parche ceremonial,
o esta placa dejada en la luna,
es evidente que Futura sobrepasó lo ceremonial,
fue más que elegir un diseño gráfico.
De hecho, Futura tenía autoridad,
legitimidad y poder gracias a esta elección.
Me gustaría concluir con esto:
y es que Futura nos cuenta una historia.
Y es lo que me encanta de las tipografías, que todas cuentan historias.
En este caso, la tipografía cuenta una historia muy poderosa
sobre la asimilación de un objeto importado a EE.UU.
que pasó a ser parte de su cultura.
Eso es lo mejor y lo peor que hace los Estados Unidos:
integramos conceptos en nuestra cultura y luego los rechazamos,
adueñándonos de ellos.
Futura refleja lo occurido con la tecnología
que apoyaba el sistema entero.
Futura fue una tipografía alemana que integramos en la tecnología de EE. UU.
Las tecnologías eran así también:
los cohetes y los científicos venían de Alemania.
De algún modo, esta tipografía alemana en una placa estadounidense
refleja a la perfección lo occurido con esta tecnología.
En este caso,
esta historia nos permite tomar conciencia de que la tipografía en la luna
representa la legitimidad y la autoridad,
proporcionándoles a los astronautas el poder de llegar a la luna.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)